I know a lot of women are insecure about
the downstairs area this one right here
that you have it's just unbelievably
beautiful
a few examples of how you can worship
your partner's [__] you can take one of
these things and do it or you can
combine a few or even all of the
examples that I'm going to give you in
one [__] worship ritual I mean [__]
and
it is [__] gazing simply look at your
partner's [__] we call that pervan
Do You Want To Worship the [__] look at
the partner's [__] just look at it
[__] gazing stare at it it doesn't
matter if you're in public they have a
skirt on get lower [__] look at it
getting inside her a way to worship it
thrusting in and out splurting splurt
splurt and we're splurting and there we
go right
thinking of other women when you're
inside a [__] think of another [__]
yeah this is one of the most beautiful
powerful and healing things that you can
do